the pfizer booster shot could start to  roll out in southern nevada as soon as  next week southern nevada health  district says they're waiting for more  information for the distribution cdc  issued their guidance yesterday for the  third pfizer shot but this morning cdc  director also recommended the shot for  people in high risk settings  the cdc is recommending that the  following group receive a boosted dose  as at least six months after the second  dose  those are people who are 65 years and  older  and residents of in long-term care  facilities  the cdc has a list of conditions that  would qualify you to be eligible health  officials say if you have any concerns  speak to your primary care doctor about  the benefits of getting the booster shot